hallo leute willkommen zu einem nürburg
wagen wie ihr euch dann wieder eure mal
wandel war es ja es tut mir leid ich war
lange nicht da es hat viele verschiedene
gründe
eigentlich hat es nur ein grund es hat
ein grund und zwar mache ich gerade oder
bin ich gerade in einem super geheimen
geheimprojekt also eigentlich ist es ein
normales projekt aber weil wir hier auf
youtube sind und ich ein instrument bin
seit neuesten weil das irgendwelche
medien bestimmt haben
im übrigen ist das video von dem space
works an ich verlinke es mal seit ich in
rente bin muss ich natürlich allen
produkten projekte nicht mache sind
super geheim und super cool und ich
würde sagen holt euch etwas zu naschen
zu essen zu trinken macht euch gemütlich
auf dem bett in einer couch oder putz
teure wohnungen rest könnte man auch mal
wieder tun ja ich meine genau durch ja
ich sehe ein zimmer das ist ich fange
mal an also was ich heute habe sehr
minimalistischen matschie denn ich war
beim asia markt also im dong dong xuan
center und habe matschies gekauft und
zwar das sind jetzt grün matschies die
haben grüntee geschmack und haben so
nennen aber auch wohnen passen füllung
also auf jeden fall es ist sehr süß und
dann war ich noch in einem anderen asia
mag am hackeschen markt gibt es
tatsächlich ein der ist relativ groß und
viel besser organisiert und viel
übersichtlicher als das jobcenter und da
habe ich moshi eis gefunden
ich liebe musik und hier habe ich auch
grüntee geschmack was nach matter
schmergow ich herausgefunden habe ich
weiß es stimmt matscher ist grüner tee
kann das sein auf jeden fall schmecken
die hier eher wie grüner tee und die
schmecken wie matt so viel wir probieren
erstmal kokos weil ich glaube kokos
schmilzt auch am allerschnellsten hier
seht ihr das
ja ich bin gerade in einem super
geheimen geheimprojekt seit ein paar
wochen schon heute noch planlos gedreht
ich muss sagen wenn man nicht nur
youtube videos macht ist das fast also
ich weiß nicht wie die anderen leute das
machen zum beispiel jetzt wo ich so
darüber nachdenke weil dieses projekt
was ich gerade mache mache ich quasi
alleine und dadurch fällt es mir sehr
schwer videos zu drehen weil ich halt
eigentlich den ganzen tag damit
beschäftigt bin wenn ich jetzt aber so
überlege ich bin ja nicht die einzige
die andere projekte dazwischen macht
aber alle anderen die mir zu einfach
eine größere projekte neben youtube
haben die haben halt auch ein riesen
team tennis welt hat ein team und macht
halt viel nebenbei flow also floyd
juli kurz zu machen es ist wie mathe
bier und kaffee ich muss es ein paar mal
essen bis ich den geschmack an meinem
leben akzeptiere
wisst ihr was ich meine bei tomate zum
beispiel keiner kann mir erzählen dass
er den ersten schritt machte nennt oder
den ersten schritt bier oder den ersten
flughafen sagt lecker aber irgendwann
nach der zeit gewöhnt man sich so dran
und so ist es auch bei matcha alle haben
große teams dabei
[Musik]
jetzt wo ich mal ein projekt nebenbei
habt ich habe keinen menschen ich habe
keine touren ich habe keinen podcast
nebenbei nichts ich mache sonst nur
youtube videos und planlos also das
format und das reicht halt immer
vollkommen zu beide jetzt neu ins thema
immer wieder dazu kommt oder neues
projekt nie hab das gefühl mir wächst
alles über den kopf und ich habe auch
immer daran gedacht jeder schauspieler
bei dem schauspieler doch einen schon
musiker die haben ja alle menschen die
immer gedacht so jacken manager braucht
man wenn man halt irgendwie riesengroß
ist und beyoncé oder madonna heißt das
glaube ich mittlerweile gar nicht also
ich habe das gefühl ich könnte gut einen
manager gebrauchen ich kann mich leider
noch nicht an den gedanken gewöhnen
manager zu haben weil das geld kostet
der mango ist noch nicht durch immer
noch einen grünen täten
für alle die es bis jetzt durch leighton
haben kommen zu einem anderen thema und
nicht warum ich so wie zu tun habe ich
feiern jedes jahr mein geburtstag den
habe ich jetzt auch bald wieder neunter
tragt euch das ein ich möchte ganz viele
glückwünsche hören
9 bitte ich gehe seit jahren also ein
letztes jahr und das jahr davor
an meinem geburtstag von appaloosa
festivals und ich war dieses jahr auf
keinem anderen festival und ich freue
mich schon so darauf endlich auf dem
festival geht zu können bei dem ex die
dieses jahr kaum ich bin ich bin so
happy
ich muss dazu sagen mein netzwerk also
die sind irgendwie ein bisschen mit dem
user verbunden ich weiß gar nicht warum
irgendwas irgendwelche verbindung
sondern überall auf jeden fall habe ich
letztes mal durch mein netzwerk
geschafft dann auch hin zu gehen weil
ich es verpennt hat der tickets zu
kaufen und dann habe ich meine
trickkiste das ganze jahr über genervt
weil ich tolle party getan wurde im
nachhinein denke ich mir auch so ja ich
hätte mir auch kaufen können
da es aber um eine polnische seele
dazwischen ich wurde so erzogen
ich habe mich schon eine jakobsleiter
von unser festival wartet ganz gut
ich denke das ist eine ganz normale
jeans jacke und als ich das dann dieses
jahr mein netzwerk wieder so lange
gemerkt habt und gesagt ich möchte da
unbedingt hin
bitte organisiert mit tickets dann habe
ich gefragt ob ich das nicht vielleicht
auch verlosen kann weil grundsätzlich
habe ich nichts gegen verlosungen oder
finde verlosungen gut wenn man halt auch
dahinter steht was man verlost und bei
dem nur ein paar jungs steckt wirklich
dahinter und dachte mir heute kann ich
nicht stecken verlosen und
ich habe jetzt zwei mal zwei tickets
fürs lola festival alles was ihr dafür
tun müsst ist in die kommentare zu
schreiben unter dem hashtag lola wandel
unter dem hashtag lollar wanne schreibt
ihr warum jeder gerne hingegen volt mit
dem jeder gerne hingehen wollt das
einzige was ihr wissen müsst ist es ist
8 999 mein geburtstag also wem die
tickets gewinnt und mich auf dem roller
seht dann könnt ihr gerne gratulieren
das ist in berlin beim olympia starter
und ihr müsst die anfahrt selber
hinkriegen also bestenfalls wohnt die in
berlin und hab dann nicht so eine grosse
anfahrt seit 18 jahre alt und ich sage
mal bis freitag 12 uhr könnt ihr
kommentieren schmeckt wie eine mango
seht ihr das die könnt ihr gewinnen und
ich hoffe ihr freut euch und ich
gratuliere ich schon mal dem gewinner
und jetzt gehts weiter mit diesen mochis
also ihr habt ihr den titel gelesen und
ich sag mal so ich glaube ich bei dem
titel irgendwas hinschreiben von wegen
bushido sprachnachricht oh mein gott ist
das wirklich passiert suite dieses
what's happening ja ich habe eine
sprachnachricht von bushido bekommen der
optimieren ich zeige euch dass das zik
vielleicht wirklich aus ist aber super
lecker ich erzähle ich die story
mein bruder war mich mit meinen eltern
besuchen und werden einem meiner letzten
buchs das gesehen gehört hat der ist
halt blind und im rollstuhl weil er vor
zehn jahren herzstillstand hatte ist
eine sehr tragische geschichte ich
glaube ich habe sie aber in dem anderen
buch bahn genug erklärt ok das ist
schwierig mit ihm zu reden tut mir so
leid die bushido geschichte so spannend
also meine eltern waren ich habe dann
600 tausend abonnenten erreichte wann
ist es passiert ganz kurz dazu flotte
fahrt das hat ja mit guten angriff
da habe ich ja ganz schön viel applaus
bekommen 30.000 oder so über paar tage
und dann habe ich ja die 500 geknackt
und jetzt sind wir schon bei 600.000 und
das ist so schnell passiert dass ich das
überhaupt nicht richtig wahrgenommen
habe und dann hat mein vater hat gesagt
600.000 getan ist und dann habe ich das
aufgenommen oder oder er hat ist dann
aufgenommen von der fahne ich das
irgendwie paar tage später so witzig und
hab dann es gepostet und dann habe ich
noch ein foto von meinem bruder das
tattoo gefunden dass sie auch an dem tag
gemacht habe und zwar hat ein tattoo auf
dem arm da steht bushido darauf die
story dazu ist das mein bruder als das
vor zehn jahren passiert ist und er nach
dem komma so wieder zu sich gekommen ist
und wieder so quasi entscheidung treffen
konnte was er so an musik hören möchte
also da hat er halt viel bushido gehört
weil und ich hab das damals so ein
bisschen belächelt weil ich auch selber
jung war und doch gehört heute bushido
hahaha ich glaube ich war damals auf dem
rock trip und für ihn wann die texte so
besonders weil er geschrieben hat über
sachen gerappt wahrscheinlich nicht im
gleichen kontext aber es war immer das
thema wenn du am boden bist du steigst
immer wieder auf du scheiß drauf es
leute sagen und machst dein ding und das
war so eine message die bushido gegeben
hat die mein bruder damals voll geholfen
hat man aber genau diese situation erst
darum gewesen
die ärzte haben nicht an ihn geglaubt
die ärzte wollten irgendwann klingt blöd
aber halt nur noch so seine organe und
wollten halt meinen eltern sagen der
wird nichts mehr da wird nur noch gemüse
im kopf sein
unterschreiben sie das jetzt hier dann
können wir noch rechtzeitig die organe
und so was rausholen und meine mutter
ist halt ein sturkopf was super ist weil
sie einmal gesagt nein nein ich glaube
das nicht ich glaube nicht dass mein
bruder ist mein sohn das so und und das
hat er halt so alles überwunden und ist
heute nicht gemüse im kopf sondern es
hat wirklich da und das happy und ist
halt der alte nur halt mit gehen dass
sie halt
im rollstuhl das ist aber auch halt
nicht so ganz also seine schul bzw dass
es auch die schuld von anderen leuten
und das hat ihm so kraft gegeben so
diese texte von ihm und dann hat er sich
dieses tattoo stechen lassen
er hat auch andere tattoos hat also ein
totenkopf und dann hat er noch so ein
herz von dem geräte dieses bgb nicht
weiß nicht wie das heißt ekg gerät nein
so ist es nicht auf jeden fall dass ihr
das von grey's anatomy oder von 1 ärzte
sendung hat dieses wo man den herzschlag
und aber sie hat auch diese bushido
tätowieren lassen stecken das noch darf
ich das heute wieder gesehen
auf dem handy und dann habt dazu gepackt
weil auch in meinem bruder dann so
meinte so kannst du ja vielleicht mal
das datum zeigen oder oder so posten
dass bushido das vielleicht sieht und
ich dachte mir ja bushido wird das aber
nicht sehen und mach ich halt man
trotzdem
und dann haben ist auch insgesamt postet
und haben alle drüber geschrieben ihn
verlinkt und und folgen nette worte
geschrieben auch nochmal hier dankeschön
an alle leute die unter dem instagram
post so nette worte an mein bruder
gegeben haben weil meine mama team ist
alles zeit vorgelesen und ihr müsst euch
das mal vor schon der ist halt gar nicht
in dieser internetwelt da drin bei als
jetzt damals vor zehn jahren passiert
ist da gab's halt schon so heisig jungen
sowas aber da diese entwicklung die hat
er jetzt nur so immer vom hörensagen
primär das hat noch nie gesehen dann von
so vielen treppen menschen zu hören du
machst es super und dein lächeln ist
toll und so es hat ihm richtig kraft
gegeben und dann kam da halt auch ein
kommentar von bushido wo er gesagt hat
tolle aktionen es gerne eingeladen toll
super und ich habe dass meine mutter
gezeigt
eine mutter dass mein bruder vorgelesen
sowohl das ist für ihn gerade so ein
denken und ich war so happy und dachte
mir nur so jamann danke bushido ich weiß
du kriegst so viele nachrichten aber
danke dass du dir diese zeit genommen
hast weil ich weiß ja selber wie es ist
man kriegt viel nachrichten und man will
auch vieles reagieren aber manchmal
manchmal habe ich einfach stressigen tag
man geht das nicht und das ist okay ich
mir dass es keiner böse nehmen aber ich
will zeit auch bushido genauso wenig
böse nehmen wir nicht gern wurde das ist
aber er hat geantwortet ich rede ganz
schnell
und dann habe ich das nochmal auf
interviews und meine sehkraft hat
geantwortet danke schön
und dann haben den kumpel geschrieben
der halt in berlin kameramann ist und er
hat auch eigenen youtube channel und ist
sehr musikalisch check thema aus link es
in der beschreibung danke ea der hatten
wir dann geschrieben und gesagt ja wir
heißen dein bruder nicht sogar quito
also ja ich guck mal ich melde mich noch
mal
er ist mit bushido in zwei tagen drehen
bushido ja und dann habe ich nach zwei
tagen wieder so weit dann gerade von
einem termin mit dem weg nach hause
gewesen und kriegst du eine sprach
leicht von ihnen ohne kontext und habe
das dann angeklickt
dann stehe ich da laufen laufen da
gerade nach hause und habe mir an wie
bushido mein bruder grüßt bei eine
minute lang irgendwas erzählt und dann
habe es in meiner hunde weitergeleitet
meine mutter hat mein bruder vorgespielt
wieso verbindung später geschrieben
kannst du mal bitte anrufen war habe ich
angerufen der mutter konnte es nicht
fassen dass er eine sprachnachricht vom
spieler bekommen hat weil ich konnte es
nicht fassen
der war so glücklich aber auch so eine
komische oder auch sony auf seine ruhige
art also du hast ihn so angemerkt ist
der er war einfach überglücklich ich
zeige euch den anfang weil sonst glauben
wir die leute wieder nicht
ich grüße dich mein name ist bushido und
ich kenne jemanden der seine schwester
vanessa kind übrigens bushido hat mein
vater gesagt mein nächstes webvideo
kommt bald featuring bushido
das hat mir ein familienfreund bei ich
bin immer für ihn da und ich mache ihnen
gerne eine freude und so aber das war
halt mal was richtiges gerichts
besonderes und da wird sich nach berlin
gezogen wenn das wahrheit schon komisch
immer so weil wir kommen aus dem süden
von hamburg und damit beginne zu haben
vor paar jahren und das war für mich
schon so ein moment wo ich ihnen so ein
bisschen allein gelassen habe und war so
einfach cool jetzt irgendwie in so einer
entfernung eine freude zu machen ja und
dann super verrückt ich habe ja dann
also ich freu mich jetzt geschieht auf
instagram ein neuer nummer 1 für ein bin
dann habe ich gesehen dass -auftritt
streamt und ich habe bushido das erste
touchscreen gesehen es war deshalb auch
mein leben bereichert bushido der mit
dem ich einfach aufgewachsen bin
den ich kenne als üblen gangsta-rapper
den ich kann ja alles richtig ghetto mit
irgendwelchen krumme menschen in berlin
zu tun und hier und da und das ist und
dann sitzt er da in einem tisch
livestream und ich dachte mir wie geil
ist das bitter weil wir dann auch selber
gesagt so ja warum macht er das denn und
dings zum beispiel wenn man ein
statement zu irgendwas dann muss man
einmal ist man darauf angewiesen dass
die interviewer leute die ein interview
das die hat auch die richtigen fragen
stellen bzw dass das gespräch hat auch
in die richtige richtung geht und so
kannst du halt wenn jetzt irgendwas
passiert wozu du halt einfach um was
sagen möchtest kannst du einen
livestream an machen und einfach mit den
leuten reden und nach eingang zeit
sondern auch video wären gemacht ich
weiß es keine
neue info aber bushido zockt world of
warcraft und das war ich fand es gar
nicht schlecht
und dann habe ich aber auch gedacht ich
habe jetzt gar nicht mehr zu essen ist
ein bisschen fake badewasser trinken
dann habe ich auch gedacht ich könnte
zocken auftritt also sims 4 zum beispiel
hatte ich mega lust mal richtig zu
spielt also länge über längere zeit des
problems aber dass ich nicht so richtig
zeit dafür habe wenn ich das zum
beispiel als livestream machen würde
dann könnte ich sagen ja das ist dann
auch ein bisschen arbeitszeit und ich
geb hat auch ein bisschen was zurück ich
bin im kontakt mit meinem mit meinen
zuschauern und und mir würde es halt
auch spaß machen dass wir halt faktisch
arbeitet privatmodus halt nicht so gehen
so viele stunden davor zu setzen und
dann habe ich überlegt ja aber so nur
zocken ist halt auch irgendwie es okay
kann ich machen und aber irgendwann wird
wahrscheinlich sind es vier auch ich
weiß nicht wie lange ich das spielen
könnte und dann habe ich gedacht puh
bank bank könnte ich eigentlich voll gut
auftritt stream weil ich kann das hier
auch immer schneiden und das ist auch in
ordnung aber manchmal das gefühl dass es
irgendwie cooler mehr wenn man wirklich
wenn ich wirklich einfach essen könnte
und dabei quatschen und egal ob ich
jetzt in dem den ein bisschen zu lange
im mund ab und zu lange drauf rum
es bleibt einfach weil die leute ja da
sind und zu hören oder das nebenbei
laufen haben und so muss ich halt immer
doch schon schauen okay das war eine
ganz große pause ich weiß ja nicht viele
könnten dass er wahrscheinlich auch
gerade wie ein post podcast hören was
ich gut finde weil ich höre selber vor
gerne podcast ich habe einmal gedacht
dass so kritsch fleisch irgendwie besser
wäre für können ihr mann sagen hättet
ihr lust dass ich auf totschlag bank
mache ich kann hier auch im nachhinein
hier hochladen kann das ist ja gar nicht
dann so als wäre dann halt umgeschnitten
glaube ich würde ich das machen würde
vielleicht best of best of essen
gesundheits update ich weiß nicht ob man
das gerade merkt mir gehts heute nicht
mehr so gut ich hab da so kopfschmerzen
es liegt irgendwie helicobacter falls
irgendjemand nicht mitbekommen video
drüber gemacht ich gehe jetzt mal davon
aus dass alle die gerade dabei sind
wissen was gesundheitlich abging
irgendwie geht es also ich hab den
atemtest man muss nämlich nach drei
monaten nachdem man dies endgültiger
genannten atemtest machen ob das für die
charakter bakterium jetzt wirklich
draußen ist und seit ich das antibiotika
genommen habe habe ich auch so ein säure
blogger genommen weil mein körper so
gewohnt darüber wie gewohnt war
magensäure zu produzieren um ging sehr
kompakter zu kämpfen
diese ganzen magensäure hat mir aber
auch immer diese kopfschmerzen gemacht
diese kopf und nackenschmerzen verbinde
ich mich auch nicht übergeben musste und
seitdem nehme ich immer diese säure
blogger und heute hatte ich keine
genommen weil die packung leer war und
heute ging es mir echt wieder nicht gut
und ich habe jetzt so als er sich
solange diese säure blogger nehmen muss
weil natürlich jedes medikament was du
nimmst zeit nicht gut ja also ich kann
jetzt schon mal sagen dass bis mitte
september
mein projekt noch geht ich dachte gerade
die aufnahme rief nicht ich sehe mich
jetzt kurz hinlegen